MALE SPEAKER: Please welcome
Stephen Voltz and Fritz Grobe.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHEN VOLTZ: My
name is Stephen.
I used to be a trial lawyer.
FRITZ GROBE: And my
name is Fritz.
And I used to be a professional
juggler.
On a Saturday morning in June
of 2006, we posted a
three-minute video online that
ended both of our careers.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: It did
start new ones.
FRITZ GROBE: Yes.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: It's great to be
here at YouTube, especially
for us, since that's sort
of our home base.
You guys, since we've started,
have really grown.
It started with home video
and viral video.
And now you're doing news, and
music videos, and programming,
and you're beginning to
replace television.
What we're really interested in
is the viral video stuff,
the stuff that people really
share actively online.
And the key question is, what
makes people do that?
What makes people
share something?
What's the content?
What is it that makes someone
watch something passively, and
other people watch something
else and make it viral?
So for the past year or so,
Fritz and I have been busy
writing the "Viral Video
Manifesto," which is
essentially an "Elements of
Style" for viral video.
It's not about what camera to
use, or how to get good
lighting, or SEO, or thumbnail
selection.
It's about the content.
Its about, what is it inside
those videos that makes people
want to share it?
We've looked at the traits of
the videos that we've had that
have gone viral, and a lot of
other videos that have gone
viral, and have looked to see,
what is it about that content
that makes them contagious?
FRITZ GROBE: So this is
a new kind of video.
And the techniques of old
media, the techniques of
television and film,
just don't work.
As we looked at our own videos
that have gone viral, as we
looked at other people's videos
that have gone viral,
and we started talking to people
like Trish Sie from OK
Go, Judson Laipply, Matt
Harding, Charlie Todd--
started to see that, yes, there
are consistent patterns.
There are techniques
that work.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: When we first put
that video online back in
2006, we told one person.
We were really weren't
ready to go live yet.
So I just told my brother
David in San Francisco.
And he told a friend of his in
Seattle, who put it on Fark.
By the end of the first day,
we had 14,000 views.
This is back in 2006.
By the end of the second day, we
had tens of thousands more.
And now it's become a viral
video classic, with millions
and millions of views--
hard to count because of so many
bootleg copies, actually.
FRITZ GROBE: And after we
posted that first video,
Stephen and I, we were both
going to be gone for the next
several weeks after that.
So we asked our friend Jason if
we could put his name and
phone number on our website--
just in case Letterman called.
Well, Monday morning, about 48
hours after we posted that
first video, Monday morning,
Jason calls and says, you know
how you asked if you could put
my name and phone number on
your website--
just in case Letterman called?
Yeah, Letterman called.
That was Monday morning.
Tuesday morning, "The Conan
O'Brien Show" called.
Wednesday, we were on "All
Things Considered" on NPR.
Thursday, we got an email from
the folks at WET Design, the
people who built the Bellagio
fountains, one of the big
inspirations for that first
Coke and Mentos video.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I was afraid
they were going to sue us.
[LAUGHTER]
FRITZ GROBE: And that was the
beginning of EepyBird as a
company and the beginning of an
amazing ride that now, six
and a half years later,
just keeps rolling.
In the last six and a half years
since that first video,
well, we've made videos
with a quarter of a
million sticky notes.
We built a Coke and
Mentos-powered rocket car,
which, actually, you can
see on YouTube in 3D.
It was directed by Rob Cohen of
"The Fast and the Furious,"
so we called it "The Fizzy and
the Furious." And we made
videos working in conjunction
with McDonald's, Coca-Cola,
Office Max, ABC Family,
and more.
Each of the major projects has
gone viral and gotten several
million views.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: And it's had an
astonishing impact for the
brands as well.
Our campaigns for Coca-Cola
spiked two-liter Diet Coke
sales in the United States
by over 5%--
twice.
And they boosted Mentos
sales by 15%
for three years straight.
FRITZ GROBE: But we didn't set
out to be viral video experts.
What we studied was clowning.
We studied European-style,
simple, red-nosed clowning.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: We both studied
with a lot of different
teachers, but, in particular,
with Avner Eisenberg at the
Celebration Barn Theater
in South Paris, Maine.
At one point, I had
a one-man clown
show up in San Francisco.
FRITZ GROBE: And I toured with
a Cirque du Soleil spin-off.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Between the two
of us, we've spent a lot of
time studying that kind
of performance.
What makes one circus act
breathtaking and another boring?
FRITZ GROBE: What makes one
clown funny and another, oh,
dear God, make him stop?
STEPHEN VOLTZ: It turns out
it's all about making a
connection with your audience.
When you're performing in a barn
in the woods of Maine,
you can't pretend you're on
Broadway with all the lights,
and the sets, and the dazzle.
You've gotta drop all that
pretense and just focus on
connecting with the people
you're in front of.
FRITZ GROBE: And it turns
out that viral video
is exactly the same.
This isn't television, with all
the crane shots, and dolly
shots, cameras covering every
angle, pans and zooms, and
quick edits.
This is reality seen through
a cell phone camera.
Television has spent decades
perfecting video production--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: You got it.
FRITZ GROBE: --techniques.
FRITZ GROBE: But online, what
you've gotta do is cut through
all that and focus on connecting
with people.
[APPLAUSE]
FRITZ GROBE: This is a
new kind of video.
All the production techniques
from TV and film don't work.
All the techniques that you've
seen in old media, they're
actually in your way.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Television uses
quick edits, and crazy camera
angles, and fast cuts, and news
crawls, and zooms and
sound effects to keep us
from turning away.
And those techniques trick us
into watching by exploiting a
primal human reaction called
the orienting response.
The orienting response is what
kicks in when we hear a sudden
noise or we see a
sudden movement.
Now, all of our senses
immediately, involuntarily,
automatically orient
to that stimulus
just for a few seconds.
Now, from an evolutionary
standpoint, that's really
important because that noise
might be a snake in the grass.
Or that movement might be
a tiger about to attack.
FRITZ GROBE: And television is
constantly stimulating our
orienting response.
A quick cut or sudden zoom
forces us to pay attention, if
only for a moment.
When that moment is gone, they
hit us again and again.
So we literally can't
turn away.
And the orienting response
is really powerful,
but it has a cost.
Literally, the orienting
response causes your heart
rate to slow.
And for a few seconds,
the alpha waves in
your brain are blocked.
That's what television does with
its cuts, and its edits,
and its sound effects.
So with television--
oh, actually it's Robert Kubey
at Rutgers, and Mihaly
Csikszentmihalyi in Claremont.
They studied TV viewers.
And they found that they report
being relaxed and passive.
And that passivity continues
even after you've
turned the TV off.
And that's exactly what you want
if your objective is to
keep people from changing
the channel.
TV numbs us into this lethargic
stupor so that we,
when we finally stumble off to
bed, we realize we've just
spent the last three hours
watching reruns of "Dukes of
Hazzard."
STEPHEN VOLTZ: But online,
putting your audience into
that kind of a trance
is a problem.
To go viral, your goal is to
get people to stop what
they're doing and actively sit
up and tell their friends
about what they've just seen.
Researchers at the University
of Pennsylvania--
Katherine Milkman and--
FRITZ GROBE: Jonah Berger.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Jonah Berger--
have looked at what makes people
share content online.
And what they've found is that,
in fact, when we're
passive, we don't share much.
What gets us sharing, what's
really most contagious, is
content that puts us in an
active, positive mood, that
gives us active, positive
emotions.
So it's things that amaze us, or
things that make us laugh--
that's what's contagious.
FRITZ GROBE: As we did the
work for the "Viral Video
Manifesto," we found that
whether you're on stage or
online, it's exactly the same.
You need to cut through the
tricks and the flash of old
media and focus on creating
a human connection.
So to create contagious content,
there are four core
principles we've found are
crucial to understand.
First, be true.
Don't fake it.
Make it real.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Second,
don't waste my time.
Get down to business
right away.
FRITZ GROBE: Third,
be unforgettable.
Show us something we have
never seen before.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: And, finally,
ultimately,
it's all about humanity.
FRITZ GROBE: And it's important
to note that you
don't have to be perfect
in all four of these.
You can go viral with a strength
in one area making up
for weaknesses in others--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Particularly
three or four.
FRITZ GROBE: Yes.
But the more you can stick to
all four rules, the better.
So let's dig into each
of these four rules
a little bit more.
So first, be true.
So we crave true, authentic
experiences.
But television gives us a
packaged version of reality,
whereas the internet, the
potential is now to give us
that raw, unfiltered
experience.
So a sneezing baby panda,
or a kid biting
his brother's finger--
these are not made by actors.
These are not made by editors.
These don't have camera
people with fancy film
school camera moves.
These are made by real people
for real people.
So contagious videos, the
opportunity with viral video
is to make us a fly
on the wall.
Because anything that interferes
with the feeling
that we are there reduces the
emotional connection.
So make us a fly on the wall--
no actors, no edits, no
fancy camera moves.
Viral videos show us real people
having real reactions
to real events.
So what really happens when
you drop 500 Mentos mint
candies into 100 bottles of
Coke, as we did, for the
Extreme Diet Coke and
Mentos experiments?
What really happens when you
send 250,000 super balls
bouncing down a hill in San
Francisco, as Sony Bravia did
for their Bouncing
Balls video?
And what really happens when a
car with an invisible driver
pulls up to a drive-through,
as Rahat Hussain did in
Invisible Drive-through Prank?
[LAUGHTER]
FRITZ GROBE: These videos
captured the real thing when
it really happened.
They didn't recreate anything.
They just captured the truth.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: In June of 2009,
a video appeared on
YouTube with the description,
"a magical moment happens in
Disneyland USA on a summer
evening when a young man
proposes to his girlfriend
in Disneyland--"
FRITZ GROBE: Registered
trademark.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: --resort."
It was fake.
If you couldn't tell from the
description, it was fake.
This video has dozens of shots,
lots of cuts, a crane
shot, I think, probably
three or four
cameras, the perfect couple--
this is a toothpaste
commercial.
The folks at Disney didn't
trust that a real wedding
proposal would be interesting
enough to go viral.
But consider this--
that same month, Jill Peterson
and Kevin Heinz from Minnesota
posted video of their wedding
party going down the aisle in
the JK Wedding Entrance Dance.
This video was real.
This video was one of the
most popular viral
videos of the year.
FRITZ GROBE: Now, coming from
the circus, I've seen a lot of
great handstands in my life.
This is not one of them.
But it's beautiful.
These are not the greatest
dancers, but we love them for
that because they're real.
So JK Wedding Entrance
Dance, it's true.
And then there's nothing
in the video production
techniques that interfere with
the feeling that we are there.
It's shot with one camera, no
edits, there's no second take
for this video.
So what you want to do is just
throw away the script, trust
the truth, and just turn the
camera on and get everybody
dancing down the aisle.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Our next rule
is, don't waste my time.
For us, that means nothing
but money shots.
If you've got a baby monkey
riding backwards on a pig,
show us that immediately.
As Elvis said, a little
less conversation,
a little more action.
FRITZ GROBE: And as Natasha
Veruschka, the queen of
swords, said, less chitchat,
more swallowing.
She's a sword swallower.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: We learned this
lesson the hard way, with our
Extreme Sticky Note videos.
We had spend months developing
dozens of really cool effects
with sticky notes.
We used these--
FRITZ GROBE: Zigzag pads.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Zigzag pads.
They're made for pop-up
dispensers.
So you pull one out, the
next one comes out.
And we discovered you
could make a little
waterfall with it.
FRITZ GROBE: In fact,
we spent about three
days exploring this.
Literally, one of the first
ideas we had was, it seems
like it should be able to
flow like a Slinky.
But you can see, it catches.
It doesn't quite work.
I kid you not, for three days
we tried everything
we could think of.
We made sculptures,
and puppets, and--
after three days, if finally
occurred to us to try this.
That was it.
That waterfall led us to--
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So that's about
4,000 sticky notes.
For our Extreme Sticky
Note video, we had a
quarter of a million.
But how did we start?
FRITZ GROBE: So let's
take a look.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So first, there's
a woman at her desk.
And we're watching our
old video, and then
her boss comes out.
And he seems like he's
kind of a jerk.
And he gives her lots
of work to do.
And she gives him a look.
Then finally, he leaves, and
then we go by this guy, who's
not doing anything.
And then there's a couple guys
in the back that look like
maybe they've got-- these guys
are us, and they've got a
couple of--
it's a complete waste of time.
FRITZ GROBE: So that video
started with an agonizing 58
seconds of that before we got to
what we promised you, which
was extreme sticky note
experiments, with hundreds of
times what you just saw there.
So there were some compromises
that were necessary.
That video actually debuted
simultaneously online and on
television, so we had to be
working within the rules of
television as well.
But we'd like to show you a
video that we made just for
internal purposes in the very,
very early days of working
with sticky notes.
This was just our little video
to say, this is what we're
working on.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: It's a proof
of concept for us.
FRITZ GROBE: Proof of concept
to give us a hint of what we
might be able to do.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
FRITZ GROBE: So that
video doesn't have
any of the big effects.
That's literally a few
hundred sticky notes.
But there's a lot about that
video that we liked better.
The big video, it took 58
seconds to get started.
That video, it's all over
and done in 58 seconds.
So we found ourselves wondering,
how many people
watched the big video and just
switched over to something
else before we got down to
business, before we showed you
what you're there to see, which
is crazy, cool stuff
with sticky notes?
Now, the big video,
it did well.
It got several million
views, won some
great industry awards.
But it could have
been a lot more.
So what got in the way?
Well, story got in the way.
It turns out that, unlike almost
all other forms of film
and video, viral video
is not about story.
Advertisers, filmmakers, we're
used to thinking of everything
as a story because stories are
powerful tools for grabbing
and holding attention.
But surprisingly, in viral
video, story is
just a waste of time.
One of the most important things
we realized is that
viral video-- actually, it's
under the heading of, The Most
Important Idea in This Book--
is the 21st century side show.
And in the side show, if you
have a sword swallower, show
her swallowing swords.
Don't tell us her life story.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Look at all the
top videos on YouTube, all the
viral videos.
They're not telling stories.
They're music videos.
They're novelty songs.
They're crazy dances.
They're a kid biting his
brother's finger.
They're a panda sneezing.
This is vaudeville.
This is sideshow.
So if you want to go viral, as
tempting as it may be to make
everything a story,
don't do it.
Just get down to business.
FRITZ GROBE: And just like a
sideshow act, every viral
video has a hook.
It has something that provokes
that reaction--
I have never seen this before.
And that brings us to rule
number three, be
unforgettable.
The goal in viral video is to
have something that would make
for a great carnival barker's
pitch, so that you can
imagine, step right up,
step right up--
whoops, sorry.
Step right up, step right up,
watch a baby monkey riding
backwards on a pig.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: There's a hook.
FRITZ GROBE: There's a hook.
See what happens when you drop
an iPhone into a blender.
There's a hook.
And watch, oh yes, watch a
guy dance Gangnam style.
There is something we have
never seen before.
And all these videos
have great hooks.
So how do you find a hook?
Well, for us, we try to do
something different and then
take it further than
anyone else has.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: For us, in our
work, it means doing way more
exploration than anyone
would expect.
You want to explore your corner
of the world until
you're the world's leading
expert, until you own it.
I would venture to guess that
Fritz and I are the two
world's leading experts on
dropping candy into soda to
make geysers.
FRITZ GROBE: Candy sodology.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Candy
sodiology.
FRITZ GROBE: There we go.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: And in the same
way, we started out to be the
world's leading experts, our
goal was to be the world's
leading experts in sticky
note waterfalls.
You want to explore your idea
like that until you own it.
And that may get you
to unforgettable.
FRITZ GROBE: So looking back,
OK Go owned dancing on
treadmills in "Here it Goes
Again." Cleary and Harding
owned dancing with their hands
"We no Speak Americano." Each
of these videos was unlike
anything anyone had seen
before, and as a result, got
millions of people telling
their friends, oh my god,
you've got to see this.
So when we talk to people who
want to make viral videos, we
ask them, what odd thing are
you passionate about?
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So I liked
being a trial lawyer.
I really enjoyed it.
But except when I was actually
in the middle of a trial, or
in those few crazy weeks leading
up to one, when I went
home at night, my cases weren't
what I thought about.
What I found myself thinking
about were things like, I
wonder if I can play "Stars
and Stripes Forever" on
glasses of water--
which turns out I can.
FRITZ GROBE: And I grew up
as the son of two math
professors.
And I went off to study
math at Yale.
And then I quit school
to become a juggler.
And my parents were thrilled.
But I love math, and
I love juggling.
But what I discovered was that,
when I got up in the
morning, what I wanted to do,
what I was just itching to do,
was juggle and climb through
coat hangers.
And that's what can lead
to your viral videos.
That passion, that exploring
whatever it is you're excited
about can be what tips you
into viral territory.
So our question is, what do
you find yourself thinking
about when your time
is your own?
Explore that weird little
corner of the world that
you're curious about, like we
did with Coke and Mentos, with
sticky notes, and so on, until
you take it all the way to
unforgettable.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Now, people often
come up to us and ask us
if we can guess what
their favorite part
of our videos is.
So is it that 12, 15
geysers going off
all at once in synchrony?
Is it 40,000 sticky notes
falling from the
ceiling all at once?
Is it Fritz shooting down
the road on a Coke- and
Mentos-powered rocket car?
It turns out it's
none of those.
Almost everybody's favorite
moment is at the
end, when we do this.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Now, all that
other stuff is important.
Those are our hooks.
We wouldn't be able to
do this unless we'd
done the other stuff.
But the favorite moment is that
one moment of humanity
when we throw our arms up.
And that brings us to
our fourth rule--
to make a connection,
Ultimately,
it's all about humanity.
When we throw our arms up in air
in that moment of triumph,
the audience gets to celebrate,
our viewers get to
celebrate with us, in that
absurd accomplishment.
You actually feel a little
bit of what we feel.
Neuroscientists have discovered
that emotion itself
is contagious.
So when you see us in that
actual moment, of we're really
feeling that crazy moment of
joy for a moment there, you
actually feel a little
bit of what we feel.
Just neurologically,
that kicks in.
So if you're looking to go
viral, if you're looking to
create content that goes
viral, show us
your moment of triumph.
Show us real human emotion.
Give us some real moment of
human reaction to connect to.
FRITZ GROBE: The most compelling
online videos, from
JK Wedding Entrance Dance, to
Susan Boyle, to David After
Dentist, Charlie Bit My Finger,
and, actually, one of
our all-time favorites, Where
the Hell is Matt, these videos
show us moments of--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: He's OK.
FRITZ GROBE: Yes--
moments of real humanity
and real emotion.
They show us the raw humanity
that creates that strong
positive emotion.
And that strong, positive
emotion is something that we
want to share.
We want to share that experience
with our friends.
So finally, we'd like to take
a look at one of the hot
videos of the month and see how
it stacks up on the four
rules from the "Viral Video
Manifesto." This is the
Drive-through Invisible Driver
Prank from Rahat Hussain.
And I'll give you some sound.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And what I'm going to do with
this costume is, I'm going to
put it on, and I'm going to go
through a drive-through.
-Hi, just a brownie?
-Yeah.
-Oh my god.
-Am I tripping, son?
[LAUGHTER]
-Come here.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
FRITZ GROBE: So that's just a
little bit of that video.
So let's take a look at how
it does on the four rules.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So first,
rule one, be true--
great.
It starts out, it's just him
in a parking lot explaining
what he's going to do.
There's no set.
There's no studio.
I think it's just on the
hood of his car.
And that tells us immediately
we're seeing something real.
And then he begins to explain
what he's going to do.
And he explains the prank.
Now, pranking someone's
not true.
You're being dishonest
for a moment.
But with us, we're
totally in on it.
He's completely authentic, and
it's clear to us, also, that
he's being straight with us.
So high marks there, as well.
And then there's the seat.
He shows us exactly
how it's made.
It's just cardboard covered
with fabric.
And it's not very good.
It looks like cardboard
covered with fabric.
But it's good enough.
And he knows that.
And he knows that in the
lighting, and the setting that
he's going to be doing
it, it will work.
But for us to see that lousy
cardboard and duct
tape back is great.
That lack of polish helps all
of the audience realize--
this is for real.
This is really happening.
The shinier it is, and the more
polished it is, you begin
to get into areas where people
may not trust you.
So showing us that mediocre car
seat costume really helped
with the truth of it all.
And then, for the rest of the
video, he shows us what Allen
Funt, who was the creator of
"Candid Camera," who invented
this kind of entertainment back
in the '40s, with radio,
called people in the act
of being themselves.
So it's just real reaction
after real
reaction after real reaction.
And it's there that he really
hits it out of the park.
So very true, very high marks
on rule number one.
FRITZ GROBE: And rule number
two, don't waste my time--
again, he does very,
very well.
It's basically just setup,
punchline, punchline,
punchline, punchline.
Its very, very simple.
The structure of sideshow
is set-up and pay-off.
You need just enough set-up so
that you understand what
you're about to see.
If you don't understand that
the sword is real, then it
doesn't make the sword
swallowing as real.
So what he does here is just
say, I'm going up to a
drive-through.
Here's my costume.
Here we go.
And then its punchline,
punchline, punchline--
really, really good.
A word about the edits,
about the cuts.
So he goes from one reaction
clip to another.
And with rule number one, be
true, your goal, ideally, is
one, un-interrupted shot so that
you maximize the feeling
that you're just there.
And every cut pulls
us away from that
feeling, ever so slightly.
But here the cuts are
to save us time.
We don't need to watch
him driving from one
restaurant to the other.
You want to give us nothing
but the money shot.
So that's where rule number
one, be true, actually
competes with don't
waste my time.
And he uses edits, like we
sometimes do in our videos,
just to keep moving from one
money shot to the next.
So that's what he does.
And he does it very well.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Rule three,
be unforgettable.
This is usually the toughest
one, and the most important.
And here it's really
interesting, because we've all
seen a magician be
invisible before.
That's not new.
And in fact, the idea even of an
invisible driver isn't new.
There was a photo that
went viral a couple
years ago with this.
You can see the hands
at the bottom.
So even that wasn't new.
But what Rahat does that is
really unforgettable is he
gives us those human
reactions.
Those people are actually
experiencing something
unforgettable.
None of those people we saw in
the video are ever going to
forget the time they went to
hand the brownie to the person
in the car, and there
was nobody there.
And we get to see that.
So he shows us moment after
moment after moment of people
having an unforgettable
experience and experiencing
that surreal reality that he
puts in front of them.
What's that one woman say,
am I tripping, son?
It's like, that's the
world we get to see.
And we get to be part of that.
So on unforgettable, even though
he takes something
we've all seen before, a
magician being invisible, he
really hits it out of the park
by showing us the reactions of
people to what he's got.
FRITZ GROBE: And that is a
direct line into, ultimately,
it's all about humanity.
This video just shows us the
fun reactions, the funny
reactions, just that awesome
humanity that we get to relate
to on screen that's so
incredibly powerful.
So this video does really
well on all four rules.
It's no surprise it's gotten 30
million views in the last
couple weeks.
It's doing very well.
So with viral video, the
bottom line is this--
it's about connecting
with people.
And that's what "The Viral Video
Manifesto" is really all
about, connecting with people.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: And the ways to
connect with people haven't
changed for thousands
of years--
be yourself, don't waste my
time, show us something we've
never seen before,
and be authentic.
FRITZ GROBE: Everyone has the
tools in front of them now.
Anyone can go out and capture
those moments of simple,
unforgettable humanity.
All you need today is a cell
phone and a YouTube account.
So thank you guys very much.
[APPLAUSE]
FRITZ GROBE: And I think we have
some time for questions.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering
if there's anything you
could-- so there's all these
positive things you can do to
make a viral video.
Are there also, like, opposite
things, or additional things
that you can do to make
sure that your video
would never go viral?
Mistakes that you could make,
that even if you did these
four things, that would prevent
your video from being
successful.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I think so.
I think those are the flip-side
of a lot of stuff
we've talked about.
So add a lot of story.
Story doesn't go viral.
Story is what makes every other
kind of film and video
work, but it doesn't get people
leaning forward and
telling their friends.
A lot of edits and a lot of cuts
remove people from the
feeling that they're really
there in that moment, which is
why the goal, the golden
chalice, is that one
uninterrupted shot.
Like, OK Go does that a lot, and
the wedding videos do it.
All the Charlie Bit My Finger
videos are all uninterrupted.
So the more you want to chop it
up, and edit it, and change
perspective, the more
people are going to
withdraw from that.
FRITZ GROBE: But I think what
we've found is that the videos
that stay closest to these four
rules quite consistently
do go viral.
There are videos like little
Darth Vader, for instance,
that isn't true.
It's all staged.
It's all acted.
But it's so unforgettable.
I mean, it's staggering to see
this little kid trying to use
the force, is something you've
never ever seen before.
But then imagine if,
by some miracle--
well, it could actually even
be done as a little prank.
Imagine a dad actually
pranking his son.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: If all that
Little Darth Vader was
actually shot on a cell phone
camera by some dad who did it.
FRITZ GROBE: Who goes, I'm going
to start the car right
when he goes like that,
and it's set up
like invisible driver.
That video would be even more
powerful because it would have
that truth.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: The other thing,
if you want to kill
your video, if you're hoping
it will go viral--
product shots.
Death.
Instant death.
I mean, we work with a lot of
brands, and we're constantly
fighting internal battles about,
we need to get their
brand in there where
it can be seen.
But man, if you have one whiff
of this is a commercial, it's
really hard.
FRITZ GROBE: Yeah.
Actually, way back in 2006,
2007, I was literally watching
this video going, oh, this is
great, I've got to tell Steve
about this.
Oh, this is awesome.
This is going to be so cool.
And it's all this crazy,
weird stuff.
And then right in the middle
of it, it's like--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Ding.
FRITZ GROBE: And I was
like, oh, screw it.
Next.
It was this instant--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So then
he sent it to me
just as a bad example.
It's like, look how
they ruined this.
And actually, that stuck in our
memory because it was such
a puncturing of all
the expectations.
FRITZ GROBE: Well, you go from
that active positive emotion.
You go from that, like, oh,
I've got to tell somebody
about this.
This is so--
oh.
Well, that was stupid.
So--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: It's
all be true.
On the other hand, speaking of
be true and putting product
shots in, the Will It Blend guy,
there's no question of
what he's doing.
He's got his blender there,
and his brand's in the
background.
And if he's got a blender that
powerful, after a while, I
kind of want to know
what the brand is.
But he doesn't go, and now
another commercial from--
FRITZ GROBE: Blendtec.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Blendtec.
He just does it, and it's
integrated really nicely.
But if you have product
shots--
if you had to give me one secret
weapon to kill a video,
that's what I would use.
Thanks, good question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
mentioning the whole product
shots thing.
There was a viral video last
year of Beckham kicking a
soccer ball into the stands.
And although it wasn't like,
he never held up the Pepsi
can, he was clearly holding
a Pepsi can
through the whole thing.
And just seeing that was enough
to know that this whole
thing was staged.
[INAUDIBLE]
Actually what I want to ask
about was, on YouTube now, our
major focus now is on trying
to get people to come here
every day to watch their
favorite channels.
And obviously, building a
sustained audience is very
different from having one
thing that goes viral.
And a lot of what we've seen
here are by creators who maybe
created one thing, and it got
huge, and then no one ever saw
them again, never even thought
to go back and learn more
about this creator.
So how does this fit with a
programming strategy that
somebody who wants to have a
sustained audience coming back
and watching them every week?
FRITZ GROBE: Right, right.
So when you want a sustained
audience, you've gotta produce
regular content.
You've just gotta keep
cranking stuff out.
And that makes it really
difficult to be unforgettable,
in particular, because the
pressure's on you to be
unforgettable, what,
every day?
Every week?
It's like, no.
But you can be fun, you can be
good, you can be solid every
day or every week.
But if you can stick to these
principles and instill that
active, positive emotion, then
as you produce your regular
content and build
your following,
then you can see spikes.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: The thing that
takes time, the thing that
takes budget, just because
it takes time, is the
unforgettable piece of it.
But all the rest of
the stuff is also
important and powerful.
And the question is actually
something we're struggling
with now because we've had a
career so far, of the last six
and a half years of
these big spikes.
And then we disappear and
write books and do other
things, and then we give
another spike.
And we're beginning to think
about, well, we need to build
our YouTube channel, actually,
and get people coming back.
And so we're looking to do
interesting cool stuff that's
not, oh my god, unforgettable,
in between what are going to
be like, we hope, the
tent poles, and
sort of build an audience.
And ideally, we'll go along,
so we have a spike.
And some people will stay and
see our regular stuff.
And then we'll get
another spike.
And maybe we'll get more people
to stay, and we get
another spike with another
spectacular, we call them, and
build it that way.
But I think you need the time
to get that unforgettable
stuff, or you need to
be really lucky.
But in between that, there's a
lot of stuff that you guys
probably understand better than
we do about just building
regular audience.
FRITZ GROBE: And I find, with
some of my favorite recurring
creators, people I go
back to a lot--
I really like My
Drunk Kitchen.
She's awesome.
And so she's really true.
She just has this way--
there's no pretense.
This is it's not all
glitz and glamour.
And it's not perfect.
It's her.
You get to see who
she really is.
It's true.
It has that humanity.
And again, it keeps
it efficient.
It is edited to give you the
punchlines, to give you
minimal set-up, punchline,
set-up, punchline.
So while those edits do pull
us away a little bit, they
also keep from wasting
our time.
So then, every once in awhile,
an episode of something like
My Drunk Kitchen comes along
that I'm like, oh my god, that
was so good, I've gotta share
that with my friends.
And then I'll come back to
watching it, and watching it,
and then go, oh my god,
I've gotta tell
people about this one.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: The last thing
I tag that with is, some of
the people who've been the
biggest successes in TV have
followed a lot of these rules,
because they're themselves.
So Johnny Carson.
And Ellen is really great.
She's Ellen.
You turn around, it's
like, that's who
you get all the time.
She really is who--
what you see is who she is.
We actually did the show, and
she's just like that.
She's super nice.
And letting that come
through, Tom
Bergeron is another example.
He's just a really good host
because he just is under
control, and he has
a good time, and--
FRITZ GROBE: One of the fun
things about Tom Bergeron is
that he came from the same
performing arts school in
Maine that we went to.
And that has encouraged this
kind of, be true, cut through
all of the tricks and the flash
and just be yourself.
[INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So subtract out
the unforgettable, and those
personalities are, in large
part, really powerful, I
think, because they let
themselves be who they are.
And that's--
AUDIENCE: What about
Stephen Colbert?
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I think that's
a great question.
I think Stephen Colbert is
saying, let's play this game.
I'm Stephen Colbert, and now
I'm going to pretend to be
this guy over here.
And what would he say?
It's like a party game.
But I think we know who he is.
At least, we know the
game he's playing.
We know that he's
playing a game.
If he was, I'm going to try
and do this completely
straight, it would be weird.
I don't know if that
would catch.
AUDIENCE: One is, if you had
to do a viral video with
everyone in this room,
at this venue, what
would you come up with?
And the second question
is, do you ever
get viral video block?
You know, similar to
writer's block?
STEPHEN VOLTZ: [LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: Are you ever stuck,
and can't come up with an
idea, and do you ever
doubt yourself?
FRITZ GROBE: Yes.
Absolutely yes.
To bite off the second question
first, so when we set
out to make our second video,
which is a sequel to the
Extreme Coke and Mentos
Experiments, it was called the
Domino Effect.
And the idea was, it was 250
geysers spread out over a huge
field in Maine.
And we pulled a pin that set off
the first Coke and Mentos
geyser, that then triggered
the next geyser, that then
triggered the next in this
giant chain reaction.
That was our second novel.
And it had all of the
second novel agony.
It was so incredibly difficult
to go, all right, we're going
to try to do this again?
And it's always daunting.
In particular, the day of
shooting, it was the single
most difficult day in
our history, because
literally, it took--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I'm
remembering.
FRITZ GROBE: --eight hours
to set everything up.
And so literally, we're
checking everything.
I'm walking along
double-checking everything,
because if this works,
it works.
If it doesn't work, oh man.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: There
was no other times.
We had everyone had come
out to set up.
And then the weather
was getting cold.
And if we didn't
shoot it then--
FRITZ GROBE: This was our
chance to get it.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: --it
was going to be
like spring or something.
FRITZ GROBE: And it
was a hot day.
So all the soda has been sitting
out for eight hours
with little Coke and Mentos
nozzles on top of it.
The soda--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: So we had a
little tube on top that had
the Mentos inside.
So they're sitting up there, and
you pull a pin, and then
they'll drop in, and that'll
cause a reaction.
FRITZ GROBE: So the soda's
been evaporating up--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Little bits
of it, all afternoon.
FRITZ GROBE: --and condensing
onto the
Mentos inside the tubes.
So at the very last minute,
I had to fix one nozzle.
And I look, and the Mentos
are sticky--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Which means they
may be stuck together,
which means they may not drop.
So the entire set-up may
be just stuck together.
FRITZ GROBE: So I walk
over to Stephen as
we're getting ready--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: And we're like,
we're ready to roll.
FRITZ GROBE: All the cameras are
ready, and I go, just so
you know, this may not work.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Let's find out.
Actually, if you look carefully
at that video, you
can see that conversation
going on.
FRITZ GROBE: Yeah, it's
like, oh boy.
But particularly where
the objective is this
unforgettable, which can feel
so daunting, really, what we
do is just go, all right, what
are we interested in?
Right now, we're
playing with--
can I say?
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Oh, yeah.
FRITZ GROBE: Right now we're
hanging upside down.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: That's right.
FRITZ GROBE: And it's just
about, let's explore it.
Let's see what we find.
And then, at a certain
point, we go, yeah, I
think we found something.
Let's film it and see
what happens.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I think the issue
for us now is more-- and
this actually goes to question
about what would we do with
the people in this room to
make something viral--
is time.
To get to that unforgettable
stuff, you have to explore
sticky notes, or Coke and
Mentos geysers, or paper
clips, or paper airplanes, or
whatever it is that you're
interested in, really
thoroughly, and go past where
anyone else has gone before.
And if you're doing sticky
notes, that's easy.
No one's ever done
that before.
So in a couple of weekends, we
were ahead of the whole world
on sticky note waterfalls.
And then we just needed to
explore it enough so we felt
like we had sort of a critical
point of enough content.
And when we're working with
sponsors, in particular,
they're often time-crunched.
They want something
by March 2.
And that's the difficult part.
But I think if we have time, I
think we've sort of figured
out our process enough now to
feel like, if we have the
time, we could do it, which is
probably why I don't think we
could do a viral video
right now with the
people in this room.
But if you guys want to come
back every afternoon for six
weeks, we'll have something.
FRITZ GROBE: We can do it.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I don't know what
it will be, but we will
totally have it.
FRITZ GROBE: We live way out
in the woods of Maine in a
town of about 1,500 people.
And it's really, really helpful
that there's not a
whole lot to do.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN VOLTZ: There's drinking,
which is what a lot
of the other residents do.
FRITZ GROBE: Where we live
really lends itself to that,
like, all right, let's spend
the next six months
exploring how to--
I mean, building the Coke
and Mentos rocket car.
It took years, in between
everything else.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Not
solid, but yeah.
FRITZ GROBE: It took forever.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: From the
idea to when we
actually did it, it took.
FRITZ GROBE: From the very
first, like, sitting on a
skateboard with four geysers.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: You went
about this far.
FRITZ GROBE: Yeah, it was
literally like, [WHOOSH].
It's all about those
little victories.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FRITZ GROBE: If you look online,
there is the Coke and
Mentos rocket car early
experiments--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Which is actually
better, in some ways,
than the actual Coke and
Mentos rocket car.
FRITZ GROBE: Yeah, you will see
just how pathetic it was.
AUDIENCE: This assumes that the
video speaks for itself,
and all these four components
are within the video.
But for a channel that's just
starting out, how would you,
in this world of curated
content, where would you share
your video?
What sort of sites would
you post on?
Would you share on
other sites?
Is there a certain
outside-of-the-video virality,
I guess, rule book.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: I think the
answer is there absolutely is,
and we ask other people
to help us there.
FRITZ GROBE: Yeah, I mean, what
our focus has been on is,
is this "Elements of Style?"
There's all of this knowledge
that's been gathered for
decades about how
to make a TV show.
But what is the content?
How do you make a video
to go viral?
STEPHEN VOLTZ: But
you're right.
When we started, when we put
what we call experiment 137,
our first Coke and Mentos,
online in June of 2006,
content by itself could
rise to the top.
But really, we told
one person, and
then it was on fire.
And now there's so much noise
out there, you need to figure
out some strategies to just rise
above the noise and then
travel on your merits
across the internet.
But rising above the
noise is a project.
FRITZ GROBE: One of the curious
things that we can
tell you a little bit about
the Coke and Mentos rocket
car, where what we found
was that it caught
on amongst car fanatics.
And that, in particular, when
we released the second video
of the Coke and Mentos rocket
car mark two, we were able to
go, it's a new world record.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Ah, that was a
great hook, if you can get a
new world record.
FRITZ GROBE: Now, we're
the only competition.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: That's right.
[LAUGH]
FRITZ GROBE: So it wasn't like,
oh, we beat the German
engineering on this.
It was simply, we built one
that went further than the
last one we built.
But that hook got it into all
kinds of car- and driver-type
blogs, and magazines,
and things.
So we were, along the way,
looking for the places where,
is this going to appeal to art
people, with sticky notes.
Is this going to appeal
to engineers?
The Coke and Mentos rocket car
ended up taking hold on some
green websites.
Now, it goes about one foot
per liter of fuel.
So it's not exactly a
fuel-efficient vehicle.
But--
STEPHEN VOLTZ: But they got a
kick out of it as sort of an
alternative energy hook
to it that got them.
FRITZ GROBE: --as a funny way
to talk about, hey, let's
think in new ways about
fuel efficiency.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: As a ways that
you guys can take away, if
you're trying to work on a
project, world records are a
really good hook.
That often gets news headlines
and attention that can bring
you more views.
And if you're doing something
like sticky notes, or paper
airplanes, or whatever your
thing is, you can set your own
world record, and then
you can break it.
So it's a plan you can have
going forward, if once you've
become the owner of that little
space, you can then
start using hooks like world
records to get attention and
get your video above
the noise.
FRITZ GROBE: So thank
you guys so much.
And we hope you'll visit our
website, and send us emails,
and Tweet, stuff like that.
We'll see you later.
STEPHEN VOLTZ: Thanks a lot.
FRITZ GROBE: Thanks.